on va passer aux câlins le plus gênant
du monteil à gagner d'une émission on se
rencontre et en fait on devrait s
embrasser tout de suite pour voir si sa
6e match sans rien et là dans les dents
les vaches vous ce qu'on va voir
vous allez voir que la rencontre bon
elle se passe mais alors c'est une carte
à quel âge tu vois que c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il avait évidemment reconnu maxime gagné
n'était cirque est tellement facile mais
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le pauvre
petit josh quand même il n'a jamais
embrassé deux femmes de sa vie c'est un
total novice il avait déjà passé une
meuf de tout ça elle a toujours pas fait
quatre cinq épisodes plus tard il va
enfin donner son premier baiser mais va
se faire charrier tout au long il ya
même eu neuf qui va dire genre dans
l'épisode suivant
j'ai eu l'impression d'embrasser des
dents uniquement des dents tellement il
se pendra cela prenne plus tôt le
contrecoup lors elle sait parler que
c'est une vraie bête hein il ya des
histoires il ya des divertissements là
je vois pas ce qu'il ya de drôle de vous
regarder quelqu'un se faire un bisou
comme ça s'est fait dans certains cas
quelqu'un qui se voient pour la fois
qu'ils s'embrassent langoureusement ça
peut être assez intéressant
décrite dans les dents et ouvert ce
n'est pas ce qu'on va trouver une
identité
j'espère que ces sponsorisé par une
marque de chewing gum non
[Musique]